finally details on the celebrity secret
relationship that faked out the internet
last night jon lovitz in 90210 star
Jessica Lowndes Instagram these shots
between the sheets a bed of roses giant
diamond ring immediately speculation was
the 58 year old SNL alum was engaged the
27 year old the amount of people and
close friends of mine that actually
thought I was for real my business
manager was asking if we shouldn't share
the ring where'd the ring come from was
it real that was a picture from Google
turns out it was all to promote
Jessica's new music video deja vu our
lauren zima sat down with the folk
couple today all right you guys you got
us all whose idea was this you are the
comedic genius here but it was yours I'm
a giant goofball and a lot of people
don't know this about me and I love
playing practical jokes
so the prank was that you guys are
dating can we set the record straight
are you single are you single I'm single
oh well then I'm single the younger
women like me I mean I was you know
taught to speak funny and have a big
stick and it works if we were together
you know that
believe me there'd be a prenup she
wouldn't be getting a dime so it's just
ridiculous